when Finding Nemo came out people went
nuts they were in love with this movie
they loved the characters they loved the
underwater world they loved the colors
they loved the story people absolutely
fell in love with it and well I don't
think it's quite as strong as say Toy
Story or some of the other films it's
still pretty damn good what's the
premise we have a clownfish played by
Albert Brooks he sadly lost his wife and
all of his children to a nasty predator
that is all except for one child the one
that he calls Nemo because of his laws
he's overprotective Nemo and wants to be
sure that nothing ever happens to him
what a shock something happens to him
Nemo is taken away by a scuba diver and
putting a little fish tank in a
dentist's office in Australia of all
places that's a unique location so of
course his father is on an endless quest
to find his son along the way he comes
across a fish named Dory played by Ellen
DeGeneres she has a fun gimmick of
having short-term memory-loss which you
would think very quickly would get old
but they work it in pretty cleverly it
gets big labs and people really seem to
enjoy it and I enjoyed it too they come
across other characters like menacing
sharks schools of organized fish the
list goes on Nemo as well comes across a
bunch of interesting characters a group
of various fish who tried to figure out
a way out of their tank and back to the
sea their plan is so creatively out
there that it's impossible not to
actually think it might friggin work but
they have to go quick because Nemo might
be in danger of being given to the
dentist daughter
a crazy-looking little child who has a
habit of shaking her fish to death now
that's a face only a mother can love
Finding Nemo has a solid story and some
solid characters I think this one plays
up the drama even more than the previous
Pixar films it took a few more chances
with what it could get away with and
just how serious it could take itself
and not just with the characters I think
the environment the music and the colors
really play a big part in making
everything come together from a dramatic
standpoint the sea is a very dramatic
mysterious place with many dangers and
many allies it's a great adventure that
has just the right story and characters
to
that pay off at times maybe you can get
a little too dialog II I mean come on
you know the lesson in the first five
minutes and yet they still kind of keep
hammering it but it's not a bad lesson
in fact it's one that's really more for
parents that is for kids that's kind of
different and again give kudos to these
movies for actually making lessons for
adults and not always for children you
don't see that very often I like kids
films that do that the characters are
too many to count they're all memorable
they're all fun you remember what each
of them looks like they're all
wonderfully unique creations I'm glad
they don't take the route where they
have Ellen DeGeneres and Albert Brooks
fall in love either I mean I know some
people would say it's obvious because
Ellen herself is a lesbian but you know
what any time they throw a female and a
male together usually they hook up and
especially with the mother being dead
this would be very tempting I'm glad
they did I'm glad they just left her as
a unique character a companion a good
friend that's all it was meant to be and
they didn't feel like they need to force
anything else I don't know what else can
I say about this movie it just has so
many things that a movie should have
it's adventurous it's dramatic it's
funny it's colorful it's dark it's
bright it has everything does every
dramatic moment hit a bull's eye no does
every joke get a big laugh no but a
majority do and it's obvious they're
writing from their hearts and that
passion and care really does shine
through good characters good story good
morals good visuals what else could you
need Finding Nemo it's a thrilling
adventure under the sea
you